هو الزلزال الاقوى الذي يضرب المغرب منذ
ثلاثه قرون شدته ومركزه القريب من جبال
الاطلس حول الجغرافيا الى واحده من اكبر
التحديات امام فرق الانقاذ والبحر لكن
الاضرار والخسائر تفاوتت بين دائره التاثر
الاوسع التي وصلت الى مراكش واكادير
وقطرها 400 كيلومتر ومركز الزلزال في
اقليم الحوز بقطر 60 كيلومترا تقريبا وهو
اقليم يغلب عليه الطابع الجبلي تغطي
الجبال ثلاثه ارباع مساحته فاتت الاضرار
في الحوض كبيره
الاقليم يضم نحو 40 قريه ومدينه وتجمعا
سكانيا اغلبه مناطق وعيره ويسكنه قرابه
600 الف نسمه تغلب الجبال على تضاريس
الحوز اذا وتعتبر قريه ايغيل على هضبه
محاطه بالجبال مركز الزلزال اما في
تارودانت فحجم الماساه كبير
تلتقي فيها سلسله جبال الاطلس الصغير
والاطلس الكبير تسببت الزلزال في حدوث
انهيارات صخريه في القرى الجبليه فدمر
بعضها بشكل شبه كامل
انهارت جل المباني الطينيه وتسببت الزلزال
في قطع الطرق بسبب الانهيارات الصخريه ما
ادى الى تعقيد عمليات الانقاذ
وتحولت بعض القرى النائيه الى اطلال بفعل
الدمار مع استمرار جهود الفرق الطبيه
للوصول
الى المناطق النائيه لحق الضرر مواقع
ثقافيه واثريه في تارودانت المدينه فالسور
التاريخي الاقدم في المغرب يحيط بها
وغالبيه سكانها يعيشون داخل اسوارها حتى
يومنا هذا
الى اقليم شيشاوه اديسيل تحديدا قريه
جبليه سويت بالارض كليا يعتبر الاقليم
بموقعه الجغرافي ممرا ضروريا لمناطق جنوب
وغرب المغرب